so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
don't get away with anything and so you
might think you can bend the fabric of
reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny I want villains to get punished
but do you want the villains to learn
before they have to pay the ultimate
price that's such a Christian question
while 97 of scientists agree that
climate change is real which is
different than saying that global
warming is Real by the way but 97
percent of scientists agree and so and
now we're hearing from Dr Richard
lindsen and he doesn't agree but 97
percent of scientists do so why the hell
should we listen to Dr lindsen there are
some issues where I think you could say
there was a hundred percent agreement
for instance if you were to say
CO2 is a greenhouse gas
and adding it will probably create some
warming I don't think too many people
would disagree
I think the only thing would be how much
and many people would think it would be
negligible
but no one would disagree with that
given this telephone game
where you can say something perfectly
innocent
and the politicians can interpret it as
saying oh so you agree that we'll have
warming
and that warming however small you know
they'll assume is the end of the world
well yeah this agreement but it's not
agreement with what they're ultimately
claiming that it's an existential threat
[Music]
hello everyone
I'm going to continue today my inquiry
into the fraught realm let's say of of
climate science the so-called settled
climate science I'm talking today to Dr
Richard lindsen he's an accomplished
Professor atmospheric physicist and
meteorologist having authored over 200
scientific papers and contributed to
Landmark theories in the realm of ozone
photochemistry atmospheric tides and
most recently climate stability holding
a rare view in opposition to mainstream
science or perhaps not so rare lindsen
disagrees on the role of water vapor in
current climate change models and argues
that alarmism is widespread aided by
political consensus not unlike the once
popular research on Eugenics Dr Richard
lindsen is a dynamical meteorologist
he has contributed to the development of
theories for the Hadley circulation
hydrodynamic instability Theory internal
gravity waves atmospheric tides and the
quasi-biennial oscillation of the
stratosphere his current research is
focused on climate sensitivity the role
of cirrus clouds in climate and the
determination of the tropics to pull
temperature difference his academic
degrees are all from Harvard University
he is the recipient of various Awards
and is a member of the National Academy
of Sciences and a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences the
American geophysical Union the American
Meteorological Society and the American
Association for the advancement of
science between 83 and 2013 he was the
Alfred P Sloan professor of atmospheric
sciences at MIT
he assumed Emeritus status as of July of
2013 prior to 83 he held professorships
at the University of Chicago and Harvard
University he's also been a
distinguished visiting scientist at the
jet propulsion laboratory as well as a
visiting professor at the Hebrew
University Tel Aviv University the ecole
normal Superior
the University of Paris and Kyushu
University
the first thing we're gonna
determine before we dive into the topic
at hand is why it might be reasonable
and important to listen to Dr lindsen so
we're going to go through his academic
background and uh then we'll proceed to
the to the main issue so where you you
did your undergraduate degree at Harvard
yeah if I if that's right in physics
from 1960 let's start from there okay
yeah I graduated from Harvard uh
in physics
1960s so it was a long time ago
I realized at that point that I really
enjoyed classical physics and actually
modern physics
seemed in some ways intimidating
so I continued in graduate work in
Applied Mathematics
now Harvard was different from other
places in applied math
places like NYU were very heavy into
the theoretical aspects of Applied math
Harvard applied math with solving
problems with applied math and they're
heavily into problems in meteorology and
other things
and so I ended up doing a thesis that
was really atmospheric physics
it was the interaction of fluid motions
and chemistry and radiative transfer
mostly in the stratosphere and there
were a lot of good problems I enjoyed it
the one problem with it was there was
very little experience with data
and so I went for a postdoctoral study
period at the University of Washington
and there was a superb data analyst uh
dick Reed who is on the faculty there
he's now deceased
uh and after that I went to Norway for a
year
and there was a very
able and Famous
Dynamic meteorologists there
aren't Eliason
and that was also a pleasure and during
that time
I began working on some other problems
ranging from tides in the atmosphere to
some problem called the quasi-biennial
oscillation
uh you may not realize it but the wind
over the equator at about 15 kilometers
roughly plus or minus 10.
uh goes from east to west for one year
turns around goes the other way for
another year the average period is
actually about 26 months
and that had been a puzzle
and um
we managed to find a solution to that
puzzle as to how that worked probably be
too complicated to explain
it involves you know random waves
generated by the cumulus clouds and the
Tropics interacting with the flow and
forming something that essentially would
be called a relaxation oscillator
and that's actually held up pretty well
for almost 50 years or 60 years so as
theories go that did well there was also
a problem with Tides I mean people
familiar with tides in the ocean know
that they're primarily 12 hour lunar
tides and they're lunar Tides because
the moon although much less massive than
the sun is so close that its
perturbation to the gravitational
potential is greater
than that of the Sun
but then it was observed that in the
pressure at the surface in the Earth
the tides were also primarily
semi-diurnal that is say 12 hours but
solar
and so that was a bit of a puzzle
because that had to be thermal
and uh Lord Kelvin in the 19th century
was asking you know given that the
24-hour component was much stronger why
was it 12 hours and he suggested the
atmosphere was resonant at 12 hours
and then actually
dominated the literature
until the late 50s
president meaning what meaning you know
let's say you have a
oh a
violin or something he's
stroking you get a certain note that's
because it's resonant at that note it
right displays that vibrates yeah
and so
people had figured out you know how it
might be resonant and so on but after
World War II when one had Rockets one
realized the atmosphere was not the way
it had to be to be resonant
and we figured out why the 24-hour got
trapped and so that was kind of fun as
problems like that that make in some
ways atmospheric science meteorology
geology geophysics kind of fun it's
they're great Fields so
so you like the you like the physics on
you liked physics a little bit more on
the concrete side a little bit more data
driven a little bit more down to earth
than the theoretical realm and then so
you said you were at U Washington to do
a postdoc and then you went to Norway
what happened after that and then they
went to the National Center for
atmospheric research
and I was the staff scientist there
and uh there was a sort of reason for it
it was slightly cynical
um
some of my classmates had gone into
Academia
and I was watching it what a horror show
being an assistant professor was
you had insecurity you had a heavy
teaching load you didn't have time to do
the research
so I decided that I would stay at a
research center until I was off for
tenure
I was after a couple of years offered a
10-year post at the University of
Chicago
[Music]
and um
that was a very nice experience I loved
Chicago
[Music]
and but my wife
was a little bit
insecure about the crime situation on
the south side of Chicago
and uh when Harvard made an offer of a
chair
we accepted it I left Chicago
and we came to Harvard
and uh
I spent about 10 years there as a
was I think eventually I was surprised
the Gordon McKay Professor then it was
some other chair
but uh I had a close colleague
at MIT Jewel Charney
who was a preeminent
Dynamic meteorologist but also a very
interesting guy good friend
and he died
and that has offered his chair at MIT
and I took when was that that had to be
uh the early 80s
okay so I should just point out for
everyone who's watching and listening
that uh this is a pretty
what would you call it Stellar academic
track so first of all an undergraduate
at Harvard and then
um applied PhD work at the post-doc
level in a variety of different places
including research institutions but the
fact that
Dr lindsen was offered tenure at
uchicago a tenured position to begin
with that's not the normal uh mode of
making an entry way into Academia
usually you start as an assistant
professor and so that's untenured and
it's very rare to be offered a
first-time job
as a tenured professor was that
associate level or full professional
that was associate I wasn't promoted
until a few years later
right and then okay so from the
University of Chicago then you were
offered a Harvard chair and I want to
point out to everyone who's watching and
listening again that that's very rare So
at Harvard
the the hiring streams are really broken
into two segments and so you have
faculty members who are hired as
assistant professors so that's the most
junior level of Professor and those
positions are not tenured at the Ivy
Leagues generally speaking and so what
the Ivy Leagues do is bring in promising
young people at the assistant level but
turn them over and that gives lots of
people a chance to work at the Ivy
Leagues and it gives the students a
chance to be in contact with Dynamic
young researchers let's say and that but
the second hiring stream and the more
important one is the senior professors
and that's usually at associate or full
Professor level and what Harvard did
when I was there that was in the 90s was
and I am sure the practice still uh
still continues and is characteristic of
IVs in general is they look all over the
world
for the people who are doing the top
research in their areas at a relatively
senior level and then make them an offer
see if they can entice them to come to
Harvard and so that doesn't happen to
very many people it's very very rare
occurrence it's not that huge university
Harvard and there aren't that many
professorships so to be offered a chair
there is uh well it's a mark of I would
say Universal esteem devoted directed
towards a given Professor within the
confines of their research and they have
to have made quite a splash on the
research front for that to happen and
then to move from Harvard to MIT well
the same thing is the case there because
well Harvard and MIT battle it out for
priority let's say for the most
prestigious and high qual highest
quality University in the U.S and
possibly in the world could have an
argument about that but to move from
Harvard to MIT is is well that's another
indication of a stellar academic career
so you went to MIT in the 1980s yeah and
uh you then you you were there until you
retired yeah until uh I retired formally
in 2013. but you know they've been good
to me I have an office and you know some
assistance occasionally and of course
one of the things is you you no longer
have students well that's a bit of a
drawback of occasionally however have
colleagues
and even you know at the end of it
for reasons that are obvious I had
almost no funding
uh but there were some postdocs who were
paid who paid their way from South Korea
so that was helpful
men is it time to stop mindless
scrolling time to finally gain that
higher quality of life you know you're
missing out on if this sounds familiar
then on January 9th join thousands of
men all over the world to embark on a
90-day journey together in search of a
better life
it's called Exodus 90 and it was built
to help men enjoy the freedom of
becoming who they were truly made to be
Exodus 90 guides you in removing the
attachments that are holding you back
from a better life and it actually works
independent research shows that Exodus
90 men report considerable shifts after
the first 90 days including stronger
satisfaction rates in their marriages
more meaningful prayer lives and
dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones
for the past seven years Exodus has
helped more than 60 thousand men build a
road map for living with virtue in a
culture that offers far too many paths
to self-destruction
is it time for your Exodus we start
January 9th find resources to prepare
for Exodus at exodus90.com Jordan that's
exodus90.com Jordan
so so did you have a preference for
Harvard or MIT in terms of the students
you encountered
not really I mean the students I
encountered changed over time more than
they changed with place
uh when I
came to Harvard
the students in my area
were I would say in some ways coming
from math and physics
mostly they were the Overflow and there
were lots of kids studying math and
physics so they were good and you know
very good in fact
and that was sort of true when I came to
MIT
but by the 90s
things changed a little bit
um first of all
good students were not entering physics
and math
at the level that they had once had did
the best students often were going into
Finance
things like that right right
and so there was no overflow and I think
there was a slight change in the nature
of students uh they were not as
theoretical they were more model
oriented and so on
uh there was also a change at MIT which
was not something we wanted
which is it was getting harder and
harder to find people working with data
and so the students were getting less
experience with actual data
but those are changes I mean
compared to current changes they
probably were minor I mean at the moment
uh
I just find it strange
there's so much emphasis on racism in
the neurosciences and so on I'm I'm sort
of glad I'm not teaching at this point
yeah yeah
it's that that one-trick pony that
ideological insistence that
something approximating critical race
Theory should dominate every single
discipline and and it gives people who
really have no background whatsoever in
these fields the opportunity to dominate
and it's it's really quite an appalling
thing to see yeah we'll see one other
thing too
which is the uh vast increase in both
numbers power and importance of
Administrators
yes yes definitely
yeah I mean yeah well you know it's I I
I think in some ways we live inside a
giant whale carcass that's walking on
the beach and well really it's it's a
good biological metaphor and there's
there's plenty of food for everyone for
a very short period of time and the
administrative overload in the
university is something remarkable to
behold especially because it's been
built on the backs of students and their
student loan their student loan oh yeah
but it's like indentured servitude I
would say it's it's more than that
um
it's you know you now have
administrators certainly outnumbering
faculty and in many places outnumbering
faculty and students
um and they need money
but they do not do the functions that
the university gets paid for teaching
research and so on
and so we have overhead on the grants
and that has become critically important
um the more overhead the better the
administration likes you so you know if
you have a big Laboratory
you'll have more overhead than someone
who does theory
and if if you're interested well when I
was there we were paying about 50
percent in overhead costs yeah remember
correctly for a given Grant so
scientists spent about a third of their
time in the United States it's one of
the reasons I was actually happy to come
back to Canada as the scientists I knew
in the U.S were spending one third of
their time writing proposal taking a
shot at about a five percent chance at
getting a large Grant and 50 percent of
that went to overhead yeah it was quite
the it was quite the waste of time for
the scientific Community because that
meant you know the brightest people
um in in our community were spending 30
30 percent of their time at least
writing grants that had a pretty low
probability of success yeah instead of
and then you know the well and you know
of course that the problem with writing
grounds is that they you tend to have to
study trendy topics and you also can't
be very daring you have to take the next
obvious step in some real sense and only
in the improved Direction and so that
whole granting system to me looked like
looked like something approximating the
death of exploratory science
well that actually also evolved over
time when I entered Academia the
National Science Foundation actually had
very few staff
and they were eager to give out money
there wasn't that much demand for it
uh right but as the administration grew
there was also
I mean the administration plays a large
role
in the behavior of departments
uh young faculty today I mean are sunk
if they don't get grants
oh yeah and um
when we get to climate you don't get
grants if you question the current
narrative so so let okay so let let's
delve into that a bit when you were at
MIT and and and at Harvard how many how
many papers have you published
approximately between your colleagues
250 or so
okay so for those of you who are
watching and listening and correct me if
you think I'm making an error in
proposition here so when I was uh
working as a faculty member we kind of
had a rule of thumb in the psychology
department which was that if a student
prepared three publishable papers that
were sequentially linked added an
introduction to that in the conclusion
we would basically accept that as a
thesis and so the rough equivalence was
three published papers equals a PhD
thesis and you've published 250 papers
so in some real sense that's equivalent
to 80 phds now what do you think of that
for a light and logic not much but to be
honest okay so well I'm trying to give
everyone well I'm trying to give
everyone watching and listening yeah
since well if you don't really know what
it means to have a publication record
like that well I mean because so that's
what I'm trying to elucidate yeah I
think it's also a matter that has
changed with time
I mean people like well
Jill Charney who I mentioned who is the
leading figure in Dynamic meteorology
probably published 60 papers
aren't Eliason who is also a terrific
influence something that order
the pressures to publish
have increased
and so people's behavior is different
also publication has become a very
different issue
[Applause]
um
you probably know that before World War
II
peer review was very rare
and if I have students read papers from
the 19th century or the early 20th
century they're quite surprised to read
them why because they're informal
their Communications they're not
assertions of Truth
they are
looking for truth
uh and um
you know after the war for a variety of
reasons
peer review entered largely because
there was too much demand for
publication may even have been a
shortage of paper
but for instance the quarterly Journal
of the royal Meteorological Society in
the UK had a wonderful statement of what
the reviewer was supposed to do
and it said you can only reject a paper
for two reasons one is an overt
mathematical error
or lack of originality
the paper then would be discussed at the
monthly meeting
and the discussion would be included
with the paper
there is no essential thought that peer
review I mean peer review the public has
been made to think that this is the
certification of the paper
that it is somehow proven right now it's
fact right right yeah and it's nothing
of the sort
it is to see if the stuff is interesting
and it's not overtly wrong
mathematically
and not uh plagiarized
uh on the other hand it's become
something more
um I mentioned you know I had two papers
that appeared in the bulletin of the
American Meteorological Society that
dealt with climate
and my objections to the current
narrative in various ways
and they got published
they got reviewed
but in both cases the editor was fired
immediately
and oh yeah oh that's cute
that was when well when did that happen
one was uh 2000 uh
one was 1991 or two and the other one
was so you're on this early
oh yeah well you know this issue
actually began in the 60s
right and um
it was clear there was a lot of hunting
around
for some environmental issue that would
give people power on the energy set over
the energy sector
and so you know you had Earth Day in the
early 60s
but then you had global cooling
and the villain there was that was the
70s yeah well it was 60s and 70s and
continued to the 70s
and the notion there is you wanted to
get rid of coal-fired plants because
they were polluting and creating
sulfates that were reflecting light and
causing global cooling
he also had acid rain at that time yep
and again get rid of the energy sector
and both of those turn out to be Duds
and the This Global mean temperature
metric whatever it is
started increasing the 70s so they said
well this won't go
and
for a number of reasons CO2 came into
the issue one of the reasons was the
international geophysical year began a
measurement program for CO2
at monologue Observatory Hawaii
and this was uh
Charles Keeling
and it was promoted by a man called
Roger Ravel
who was director at Scripps which is an
oceanographic institution in California
anyway they noticed CO2 has been
increasing
and the evidence is it's been increasing
since the industrial era began but
serious levels
or at least measurable we're being
reached in the 50s 60s where it was
perhaps
significant in terms of heating
and why did they start measuring it
well curiosity
yeah okay okay so so that was just that
was they were just curious to begin with
yeah I mean it's an interesting chemical
it plays a role in the I mean
photosynthesis it's vital we have you
know like 40 000 parts per million in
our breath
so you know it's an interesting
substance
and part of the reason it's interesting
is of course that it has infrared
absorption and so it plays a role in
what is called the greenhouse effect
okay so they found it
and the question then was uh what are
the implications
but more than that if you are interested
in controlling the energy sector
is the fact that no matter how clean
you made the burning of fossil fuels
you would inevitably be left with the
product of clean burning which was CO2
I see I see so this was one you couldn't
get rid of it uh pollutant I see I see
so not a police fossil fuel energy
became they were never going to get rid
of carbon dioxide just like that was a
good now what why do you think there was
attempts to you you talked about control
of the energy sector why why bring that
into it
well I mean your guess is as good as
mine but it obviously is at the heart
of Industrial Development it's the heart
of the prosperity of the West
you had all these malthusian movements
Paul Ehrlich John holdren zero
population growth
um and you know you see now I mean a
kind of
antipathy to the working middle class I
you know you begin to feel there were
people who resented the fact
that ordinary people were aspiring to
live decently have a car own a house
and for some reason I think that's warm
yeah right
um you know have a dishwasher
and I don't know why but there is almost
an antipathy to this
fear off right with Black Rifle coffee
Black Rifle has all the best Brewing
gear thermoses mugs and apparel designed
for folks who love country and coffee
Black Rifle sources the most exotic Rose
from around the globe
he is roasted here in the U.S by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
every purchase you make with Black Rifle
helps support veteran and first
responder causes go to Black
riflecoffee.com and use promo code
Jordan for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear and
apparel or join the Black Rifle coffee
club for automatic deliveries to your
door on your schedule
save 10 with promo code Jordan that's
black riflecoffee.com promo code Jordan
Black Rifle coffee supporting veterans
and America's coffee
foreign
I was talking to Alex Epstein recently
he wrote a book called fossil fuel oh
yeah he uh yeah he attempted to lay out
some of the you might think theological
or metaphysical presuppositions
underlying this and you know your
comment on Envy is an interesting one
that you know there's some antipathy
towards having ordinary people thrive
which is a pretty nasty form of
antipathy his point was that the male
two so there's I guess there were two
one on the melthusian front and one on
the more quasi-religious front is that
there's an idea that the only acceptable
natural landscape in some real sense is
one that's been completely Untouched by
human beings and so if that's your
presupposition to begin with then
anything that has to do with industry is
going to be let's say persona non grata
and then if you combine that with this
malthusian notion which we could go into
a little bit so the malthusian notion
for everyone watching and listening is
it's based on something like a petri
dish model so a petri dish is an
enclosed plastic container that has a
medium in it often agar which is a kind
of gelatin that you can grow
microorganisms on and if you throw a
microorganism in there it'll start to
multiply until it eats up all of the
agar and then it'll all die and so
there's this idea that's in some sense a
biological idea that populations left to
their own devices will multiply until
they devour all their resources and then
they will perish on mass and the
malthusian predictions of population
collapse that started to emerge in the
60s were based on this petri dish model
in some real sense and the problem with
that model is that it isn't obvious that
single-celled organisms are a good
metaphor for human beings because we're
capable of extremely radical adaptation
and transformation whereas single-celled
organisms just basically run out
something like an algorithmic program
even though they're quite complex and so
the notion that human populations are
destined to a malthusian end is not what
would you call it it is not it cannot it
is not a canonical biological fact let's
put it that way but it's certainly
driving a lot of this sort of thing
we're talking about yeah I mean
it's a little bit tricky in a sense what
motivates people it's clear
that at the top they have no interest in
restricting their own consumption
um it's also
very much I mean
you know when you try and figure out
what's the right population I guess in
some sense you could say
there must be some limit but you know
you look at India in my lifetime I mean
uh
before independence and even shortly
after its population was what under 200
million
and famine was common
and today it's 1.3 billion and they're
food exporters
right right yeah I just saw a chart the
other day too that showed that over
about the last 10 years uh a fair bit of
Farmland has been taken taken out of
production and some of that's reverted
to the Wild and yet despite there be
less Farmland being used now the the
amount of food that the world is
producing is still increasing at a
pretty damn rapid rate and so it isn't
obvious at all what the upper bound is
for population capacity oh yeah I mean
uh you know agriculture has become far
more efficient
and you know this leads to this peculiar
emphasize emphasis on uh
uh food that has not used fertilizer and
so on uh you know
which yeah we're not at that point yet
that would lead to starvation
without ammonia it's four billion people
would die without ammonia fertilizer
that's the estimates at the moment yeah
I mean so I everything about this is is
sort of nuts
uh Alex Epstein who you mentioned is you
know pointed this out but it it's kind
of obvious
I've noted this I mean
you could uh do everything you know bury
the Europe very uh the US Canada
get rid of all their emissions period
all dead and buried
and it would make very little difference
to the growth of CO2 since most of the
world uh is not this stupid
as to commit suicide
and so if you really believe the
cataclysmic claims which have no
scientific basis
but let's say they're true
you're doing nothing to stop it
on the contrary you're impoverishing
your societies
and making them less resilient
because if you think natural disasters
are coming where would you rather be
today Haiti
or in Chicago or New York or Los Angeles
well it's also the case it what's also
the case that I don't I don't see any
evidence at all because you could make a
case
I arguably if you believe the carbon
dioxide climate catastrophe narrative
you could make a case that it's
ethically required to impoverish people
if you could demonstrate that that
impoverishment actually produced uh
let's say a decrease in carbon output
but that certainly isn't what's happened
in Germany since Germany's gone madly
Green in fact there are energy their
energy production is much less efficient
than it was 10 years ago and it's five
times as expensive and it pollutes far
more yeah and so my sense is that and I
think the data bear this out too is that
if you provided people with cheap clean
energy on a world basis and eradicated
absolute poverty or at least ameliorated
to the degree that was possible then
people start caring about the long term
and they start working for environmental
preservation of course at a local level
and that's a far more effective way of
taking care of the planet so not only do
you impoverish people
you impoverished people and make the
planet worse and as far as I can tell
that's just essentially unforgivable so
why do you think
so two things we left uh we left
something hanging you said two editors
got fired one in 1992 when was the
second one who got fired for published
after that you wrote 2001. it was
immediate
2001. okay and so now what what when
when you started to object to the
narrative
what narrative were you objecting to and
what grounds this is vaccine 92 what
narrative were you objecting and what
grounds were you objective you're
touching on something that took me a
while to understand
um
you know
gerbils famously said you know
if you tell a big enough lie and repeat
it often enough it'll become the truth
there's been a lot of that in this but
there are aspects of establishing the
narrative I.E what makes something the
truth that I hadn't appreciated
so the narrative was the climate is
determined by a greenhouse effect
and adding CO2 to it
increases it causes warming and moreover
the natural greenhouse substances
besides CO2 water vapor clouds upper
level clouds will amplify whatever man
does
now that immediately goes against Le
chatelier's principle which says if you
perturb a system and it is capable
internally of counteracting it it will
and our system is and you think that
applies okay so that's that's a very
germane issue because well but let me
even if please go ahead let me finish
because okay so that was a little bit
odd you began wondering where did these
feedbacks come from
and uh immediately people including
myself
started uh looking into the feedbacks
and seeing whether there were any
negative ones or how did it work
but underlying it and this is what I
learned if you want to get a narrative
established
The crucial thing is to Pepper it with
errors
questionable things so that the critics
will seize on that and not question the
basic narrative the basic narrative in
this sense was that climate is
controlled by the greenhouse effect
in point of fact the earth's climate
system
which has many regions but two distinct
different regions are the tropics
roughly the minus 30 to 30 degrees
latitude
and the extra Tropics outside of 30
degrees plus or minus
they have very different Dynamics
in the tropics
The crucial thing for the Earth by the
way and this is a technicality and much
harder to convey than saying that
greenhouse gases are a blanket or that
97 percent of scientists agree this is
actually a technical issue the Earth
rotates
now people are aware of that we have day
and night
but there is something called the
Coriolis effect
when you're on a rotating system it
gives rise to the appearance of forces
that change the winds relative to the
rotation
and
the only component of the rotation is
the component that is perpendicular to
the surface so at the pole the rotation
vector
is perpendicular to the surface
at the equator
it's parallel to the surface it's zero
and this gives you phenomenally
different Dynamics
so where you don't have a vertical
component to the rotation Vector motions
do what they do in the laboratory in
small scales if you have a temperature
difference it acts to wipe it out
and so if you look at the tropics the
temperatures at any surface are
relatively flat they don't vary much
with latitude
on the other hand you go to the middle
attitudes extra Tropics there the
temperature varies a lot between the
tropics and the pole we know that I mean
temperatures are cold at high latitudes
and if you look at changes in climate
nearest history
what they consist in is a Tropics that
stays relatively constant
and what changes is the temperature
difference between the tropics and the
pole during the Ice Age it was about 40
degrees Centigrade today it's about
it was about 60. today it's about 40
during 50 million years ago something
called the eocene was about 20.
and so that's all a function of what's
going on outside the tropics
within the tropics the greenhouse effect
is significant
but
what determines the temperature change
between the tropics and the pole
has very little to do with the
greenhouse effect
it is a dynamic phenomenon based on the
fact that if you have a temperature
difference
with latitude it generates instabilities
these instabilities take the form of the
cyclonic and anti-cyclonic patterns that
you see on the weather map
now the tropics are very different I
mean you know even a casual look at a
weather map
the systems that bring us weather travel
from west to east
at latitudes outside the traffic tropics
within the tropics they travel from east
to west
the prevailing winds are opposite in the
two sections
and where
saying that what changes due to the
greenhouse effect however you look at it
is Amplified at the poles that is not
true there's no physical basis for that
statement
all they do is determine the starting
point for where the temperature changes
in mid-latitudes and that's determined
mainly by hydrodynamics
okay that's complicated to explain to
someone
and yet and yet it's the basis for
claiming that these seemingly large
small numbers you know they're saying if
Global mean temperature goes up one and
a half degrees it's the end
that's based on it getting much bigger
at high latitudes and determining that
but all one and a half degrees at the
equator would do or in the greenhouse
part of the Earth
is change the temperature Everywhere by
one and a half degrees
which for most of us is less than the
temperature change between breakfast and
lunch
and the thought that this is the end of
the world
it's a little bit all right so let's
let's play devil's advocate here first
and so let me lay out the narrative and
correct me if I've if I've got it wrong
so
first of all the world at the moment is
making a big deal out of climate and
associating climate change with the
greenhouse effect the trapping of heat
and they're associating we're all
associating the greenhouse effect with
an increase in carbon dioxide and at
least initially we were associating that
increase in climate in carbon dioxide
with with global warming and then we've
added the proposition that well not only
will there be warming say of up to a
degree and a half or two degrees by the
end of the century uh and and maybe
there's some variation in those
predictions but we're also looking at a
system that's characterized by a variety
of positive feedback loops and those the
danger here is that a one and a half
degree increase might not be
catastrophic but that that might trigger
a sequence of cataclysmic events we hear
sometimes about the melting of the
Greenland ice ice cap for example the
rapid rise in sea level that would occur
as a consequence the increase of 10
temperatures out the pools the release
of methane as a consequence let's say of
the permafrost
thawing and then a runaway greenhouse
effect because of that and you evinced
some skepticism well about the whole
narrative but also more particularly and
perhaps more importantly you don't sound
like you're a big fan of the idea of
runaway positive feedback loops oh well
there are a lot of things enmeshed in
what you've said
even the one and a half degree depends
on the positive feedbacks
otherwise CO2 would be even less
significant much less significant
so those you know you assume that water
vapor increases and amplifies it but the
whole picture is one-dimensional so you
know it's you'd have to know the area
where water vapor is important and it
goes through a mess of things and we
know now that that probably isn't
occurring even people who support the
narrative
so you keep the water vapor isn't
amplifying carbon dioxide effects uh if
it is it has to be considered as part of
an infrared feedback and nobody is
detected that that is actually positive
okay okay well I I heard that I read
that
the punitive contribution of carbon
dioxide to
global warming is less than the margin
of error for measurement of the effect
of water vapor yeah do you know if
that's that's true that's really sad if
that's that's that's really sad if
that's true it is true if you want to
mention if you want to measure it rather
than hypothesize it
then what you're saying is true
it's been hypothesized
in other words so we're we're planning
on spending two trillion dollars to
remediate a problem whose magnitude is
so small that it could easily be hidden
within another measurement error on the
water vapor front I think so
but I mean that's really quite something
um no I mean it's caught the fancy of
the political world
I mean I'll give you an example of it
you know we're falling into the Trap I
mentioned you know going along with the
narrative because it has so many
weaknesses
uh ignores the fact that the whole
picture of the greenhouse is
misconceived
okay well let's not go too far down that
rabbit hole because I'd like to stay
focused on on the critique of the major
narrative yeah no I mean you know I'm
quite willing to talk about the other
problems yeah but the fact that you
don't have this polar amplification you
know that it's going to be bigger at
high latitudes
it may be but it's not due to the
greenhouse
it's due to processes and the extra
Tropics where the greenhouse is
secondary by a long shot
there there's one example of what you're
saying and it helps I think understand
why this issue gets so distorted
um in one of the International Panel on
climate change you know this un body
uh reports I think the third report
somewhere in the early 2000s
where I was the lead author but that we
can get to that later in any case uh
they have this thousand pages that deals
with the science has no index is totally
unreadable
and then they have a summary for policy
makers
which isn't really due to the scientists
and they can manipulate the text because
that comes out six months before the
text of which it's a summary
but you know they know people aren't
even going to read that so you you have
the Thousand Pages they're not going to
read then you have 20 Pages they're not
going to read and so you have the press
release
and the press releases the iconic
statement and that's what gets the
headlines
so the iconic statement was they now are
I forget how that's how certain
that uh most of the warming since 1960
is due to man
okay
uh in truth that doesn't mean much it
was about a half degree it was most
consistent with the climate being
relatively insensitive
it was basically a statement there's not
much of a problem here
but they didn't say that they just said
most of the warming since 1960 is due to
man
all of a sudden what is most mean does
does most mean 95 or 51 percent could
mean 51 percent
yeah okay even if it meant a hundred
percent it wouldn't matter it was small
yeah got it but how did Senators McCain
and Lieberman respond to that
they come out immediately with statement
this is the Smoking Gun we must do
something
so as long as the scientists
can make innocent remarks
and be assured that politicians will
convert them into alarm
and increase funding
why are they going to complain and so
you have this Insidious uh interaction
where scientists and you know there's
another guy Bill Steve coonan who's
written this book and I know Steve well
and
you know the point is he could use the
documents
that are cited on behalf of alarm
[Music]
to say look nobody here is saying it's
the problem that the
environmentalists and the politicians
are saying where did this come from
and the answer is it came well Bjorn
lomberg has done the same thing I mean
he accepts the ipcc predictions
essentially with some criticism but says
look well if they're right this is
straight from the horse's mouth let's
say with regard to the U.N even if
they're correct
that'll mean two things the first is
we'll be slightly less Rich than we
would have been a hundred years right
now because economic growth is so high
and we won't even notice that in some
real sense but even if it's slightly
bigger than we predict we're so good at
adapting and you can see like the curves
for example in terms of number of people
who are dying from natural disasters
each year which has declined
precipitously over 100 years we're so
good at adapting that the probability
that we can just adapt to this is a
hundred percent now that of course me
that assumes that there are none of
these runaway positive feedback loop
effects but my problem with that on the
scientific front was well how the hell
do you predict a runaway positive
feedback loop you can't predict that as
far as I can tell by the way the
feedbacks are not runaways that they're
using
they just amplify you'd have to get a
much higher level of feedback to be a
runaway system
The Tipping Point is a different
argument
and I find that kind of nutty
because tipping points
in the climate system are virtually
unheard of
and there's a good reason for it
they're usually characteristic of
systems that have what I would call
few degrees of freedom
so friends so it's saying if you want to
make a transition from one state to
another you don't have many
places to go so it has to take a leap
all right oh I see what you mean so so a
system that's constrained in its in its
modes of possibility yeah tip because
there's only a couple of states exactly
but a complex system but a system like
ours oh that's very good has an infinite
number of degrees of freedom essentially
and it can go smoothly through anything
okay has that been has that proposition
been Quantified like do people I've
never heard that before right it's it
makes a lot of sense to me that you know
a system that flips would flip because
it could be frozen or liquid yeah in the
case of water but but a system that's
complex and and highly entropic because
of that has many many ways of dispensing
looks like a formal argument yeah I
haven't seen it explicitly expressed but
I'm pretty sure there's something in the
literature about that
well it it makes sense if a system has a
multiple ways of multiple ways of
dispersing with increased energy input
yeah then it's not going to yeah I mean
the probability that it's going to do
something dramatic has got to be
proportionate in some sense to the
number of options today yeah I mean look
you know the number as I was saying
if you want to Pepper something with the
craziness this issue
has left to
speak of on that count I mean one of the
ones I like
is this metric for climate
which is a very peculiar metric you know
some Global temperature
yeah what is it Global mean what is it
how do you get it where is it
I mean how do you take the temperature
let's walk into that well some well some
of that okay so some of that is a
consequence of many many weather
stations distributed on the physical
surface of the Earth but the problem
with those is that many of them were
built in places where Urban where Urban
encroachment has expanded over a hundred
years and so that's a huge problem on
the measurement from yeah but that's
sophisticated
how do you average Mount Everest with
the Dead Sea
well I'm curious about that how how is
that done like to think of the earth as
having one temperature you
so you're making the case there that the
mean is the crucial variable right
that's really what it was well it's
saying that
uh but
it's hard to tell how you get it they
don't get it by the way by averaging
what they do okay well how else can you
get it okay what they do is take each
station
[Music]
take a 30-year average I forget it's you
know like 1950 to 1980 or something
and look at the deviation of the
temperature from that average
and they average the anomalies the
deviation
okay
so you know let's say it went up three
degrees at one station from the 30-year
mean went up two and one and so on they
average those numbers instead of the
temperature itself
okay why
and who's they
the British Met Office Noah NASA so on
everyone producing a temperature record
is doing that
okay
maybe it makes sense you know because
you don't want an average Mount Everest
in the Dead Sea but maybe the changes in
temperature at those places you could
average and get an average temperature
change
okay so you do that and they show you
the graph but they never show you the
data points
and if you show the data points and this
is a guy at Lawrence Livermore
laboratory you did this around 1990 he
died in 92. he showed the data points
and whereas This Global mean temperature
record is changing a degree a degree and
a half over a century a century and a
half
the data points are scattered over 20
degrees
right right and they're densely
scattered huge error not Ira it's just
huge range just scatter
and if you chose any given period of
time any moment
there are almost as many stations
cooling is warming even though the trend
is slightly warming because it's slight
and so when you see somebody at a given
location saying this is a cold day how
come it's they say it's warming well the
data says it could almost be as likely
to cool as warm except there's a slight
bias
and uh
it's you know when you look at the media
if there's an extreme at any given place
they say it's climate right the data you
know it doesn't suggest that
okay so so part of the problem here is
that we have a a single measure which is
this average change of temperature now
that's become uh that's become the
standard for assessing something like
Global planetary Health oh yeah now our
entire industrial Enterprise is being
bent to serve that particular master so
what do you think's wrong with the
average mean temperature as a univariate
variable I mean you talked about scatter
so that's a problem but but
the other one problem with it
is and it explains why for instance
textbooks on climate from the 40s
through the 60s
didn't discuss this metric
they discussed the fact that the Earth
had many climate regimes dozens
[Music]
and they wanted to know what accounted
for the different regimes of climate on
the Earth
something called carbon classification
this metric became popular
with global cooling global warming and
so on because you wanted to have
something
singular that showed one or the other
I think they were capitalized also on
the fact
that as a British physicist and novelist
CP snow
realized many years ago
that we have two cultures well I think
we have more than that maybe we have no
cultures but if you're not a scientist
it is amazing
how enumerate and illiterate you can be
right so or even if you are a scientist
yeah but there's there's a different
kind of ignorance
specialization and so on
but most people looking at a graph can't
read a graph
right and so you know if you look at the
financial page
people you know see the same graph if it
went up 10 points and went up a hundred
points and went up 200 points all they
see is it went up
and they rescale and they show you that
because if they only show you something
that is objective
some days it wouldn't look like it's
doing anything
and so what what would you re what would
you regard as the major drivers of look
okay let's go back even a step further
do you think that we have any
existential real existential concerns on
the climate front
not for the next five thousand years
okay okay so
so we probably don't have to worry about
that for at least four thousand I I
think so and and we would see it I mean
it's you know we had these massive ice
ages
and and every roughly 100 000 years and
the glacial part of it is longer than
the interglacial that we're in now
so yeah I mean but we're talking about
scales of thousands of years for that
that's a major change
and uh
it was understood by a Serbian
astronomer
in the 1930s early 40s
that this was largely due
to the orbital variations of the earth
which produce changes in solar radiation
incident on the Earth
in summer in the Arctic
of a hundred watts per meter squared
remember with CO2 you're talking about
two watts per meter squared three Watts
for me one and a half between the ice
age is 100.
and why summer in the Arctic
because you always have snow in the
winter in the Arctic
the question is how much of it survives
the summer
if it's cold during the summer the snow
lasts and builds up on a new base each
year
and over thousands of years becomes a
cup you know a kilometer or two of iso
for you
uh on the other hand of the Summers the
warm the snow doesn't last and you don't
build your ice
okay so so the main drivers of that kind
of that was so up a little bit
cataclysmic change that's orbital and so
and those are you said a hundred watts
per square meter right essentially and
and now you're you're pointing out that
the putative effect of of carbon dioxide
warming is something like two watts per
meter that order and that's going to
produce a a comparatively small
perturbation nothing of the order of
magnitude that's associated say with
glaciation or the lock thereof yeah I
mean and also not an amount that'll
produce positive feedback loops
you know
producing positive feedback loops I
think is a kind of funny phrasing
the feedback loops are intrinsic to the
system
and the question is do we have positive
feedback loops and I don't think so
not really serious ones and yet they're
assumed in order to get a big bang out
of the CO2
yeah okay so what on What basis are they
assumed because you already made the
case no degrees of freedom so like
what's going on here scientifically how
can that story be put forward with any
degree of credibility
by saying it's credible
I mean that's what we're doing
I mean you know in other words Suki
minabi uh did some papers in the early
70s
where he assumed essentially one
dimensionality for the system no clouds
no nothing
and uh he said if I assume relative
humidity remains fixed
and I have no clouds or I don't let
clouds change
then because of something called the
clausius club iron relation the warmer
it gets the more moisture the atmosphere
can hold and if the relative humidity is
fixed you'll have more moisture
okay and he showed you could get an
amplification a doubling of the effect
of CO2 from that
it just happens to only apply in the
tropics
and it is not the clouds are not fixed
they are also changing and counteracting
in I think
much of what's Happening due to the
water vapor and changing the area over
which the water vapor acts so it's a
much more complicated affair
and the measurements from satellites are
suggesting that the whole shebang when
put together is not producing the
feedback that you needed to double the
effect you've expressed a lot of
skepticism about computer models now
when the average person reads that a
computer model makes a given prediction
especially if it's reported in a
peer-reviewed paper they're inclined to
presume that that means two things it
means data and it means fact
but I'm very skeptical of computer
models because you have to make all
sorts of assumptions and the devil's in
the details with something as complex as
climate so on what grounds have you gone
after the climate models well you know
actually I I have a use for the models
um
there's no way that models
can accurately well there is a way maybe
simulate fluids
I mean you know the trouble is
our atmosphere our ocean
have motions on every scale
they have motions on the scale of your
fingernail they have motions on the
scale of the planet
they all have an impact that small-scale
turbulence in the boundary layer the
clouds which have a scale of a kilometer
or so the weather patterns that have
scales of thousands of kilometers
and you're modeling them on a computer
even today's massive computers
can't resolve
a centimeter that would be incredible
so they have to
assume what the small scale turbulence
does they have to assume what the clouds
do they have to assume what you know all
sorts of things are doing
and even then
there are some systems where you can
prove mathematically that as you reduce
the mesh size
of which you're approximating things
because you're you're not doing it
continuously you have to just make
points that it converges to the right
answer
but no one has ever done that for fluid
dynamics we don't know if it even
converges
so you have to in these models
put in you know often you'll run a model
and it goes Haywire you throw in damping
to prevent it from going haywire
the damping has no physical basis it's
just to keep the model from blowing up
you're doing all these things
and you're hopeful that it may still
have some insight now I said
right I actually am not against models
so for instance if you do theory for a
phenomenon in the atmosphere
you usually do what's called order of
magnitude analysis what that means is
you take the full equations
and you try to estimate how big and
small the terms are
and you're trying to see if these terms
are small can I approximate the system
with a simpler system
and can I test it in this way and you
learn a lot from that almost everything
we know came from that sort of analysis
not for models but once in a while if
things get complicated
I'd like to look at a model and see
whether there were things possibly going
on in the model that might go on in
nature that I hadn't thought about
and so the models can be useful
promoters of more thinking about
possibilities sure of course of course
of course that's very different than
assuming that they're valid models of
what's going to happen of course climate
and so okay I have two questions on that
front is like is it hard to
um approximate fluid dynamics regardless
of mesh size because a fluid system has
so many degrees of freedom it's very
hard to do
I mean nobody would pretend let's say
you have a gurgling Brook with pebbles
and so on it's doing all sorts of things
nobody's going to predict
the Eddie for let's say a mile
I mean that would be hopeless you might
make a statistical forecast on certain
things and you might get useful
information and you might be able to
make an approximation that tells you how
the roughness of the surface affected
the flow rate and so on
but it
and you know all you do is scale that up
many orders of magnitude and you have
the Earth's atmosphere and those little
Eddies that you couldn't track are now
your weather systems and so on you still
have trouble tracking them well so so
part of the issue here is that the we're
dealing with temperature changes that
are of relatively small magnitude
compared to the potential range of
temperature change and what that means
is that for that
degree of accuracy and prediction let's
say you need an accuracy of one to three
degrees over a hundred years you have to
have an unbelievably finely tuned model
at an extremely high level of resolution
and then with the difficulties in
modeling fluid dynamics it isn't even
obvious that you could do it in
principle I think that's probably true
um you know you you can restrict as I
say you damp the models you keep them
from blowing up you do all sorts of
things and
uh you know for instance
with the greenhouse picture I've been
critical of it because I think it only
really is useful in the tropics
but it is useful
if I'm comparing Venus and Mars and
Mercury
for them you know the gross idea of the
greenhouse does tell you why they're
different
but you know the changes in the earth's
climate involve miniscule temperature
changes compared to the temperature
differences between the planets right
right right right well then we have the
additional problem on the political
front that so imagine you have an
unstable climate model or an inaccurate
climate model at the scale of resolution
we're discussing and then you put on top
of that an economic model and the the
economic model uses the climate model as
an axiom and then it tries to predict
out 100 years which like I I just don't
see that as going anywhere at all
because you can't predict Economic
Development with any degree of accuracy
over a hundred year period if you could
do that you'd have all the money in the
world almost immediately if you could
generate a model that accurate you
simply can't do it no so if you stack a
bad economic model on a flawed climate
model you really do have a tower of well
and they don't even do that I mean the
economic models that people like Nord
house and so on use
just take that metric for climate
and a sign right but they assume it's
accurate and they assume that you can
put a monetary value on it
yeah and then you know tune the I mean
you know
model there are various kinds of models
that do these things but uh
I
I don't know what to say I mean I don't
think any longer that is the models that
are driving the perception
I think it is the pure repetition all
you know and this was understood from
the beginning in 1980
yeah eight when Jim Hansen gave
testimony to the Senate
uh about finding that there was global
warming
and uh Newsweek Newsweek had a cover
and the cover showed the Earth on fire
and had the label all scientists agree
right right now you know you had all
sorts of funny problems at that time
like most weather men disagreed
and the American Meteorological Society
decided they needed re-education
I mean the March through the
institutions was pretty effective
and we could talk about that I mean
that's been well I'd like well let's
talk about this because I was going to
push back at you again Playing devil's
Advocates so we hear all the time this
this idea that while 97 percent of
scientists agreed that climate change is
real which is different than saying that
global warming is Real by the way but 97
percent of scientists agree and so and
now we're hearing from Dr Richard
lindsen and he doesn't agree but 97
percent of scientists do so why the hell
should we listen to Dr lindsen and so
let's start with the 97 percent of
scientists agree claim
well yeah I mean there are a couple of
aspects to it there are some studies
like one by a man called cook that were
just bogus
they you know ended up looking at 50
papers specially selected and found you
know this percentage and this was taken
apart the Wall Street Journal by uh
Spencer and best
and it was nonsense
but there are some issues where I think
you could say there was a hundred
percent agreement
so for instance if you were to say
CO2 is a greenhouse gas
and adding it will probably create some
warming
I don't think too many people would
disagree
I think the only thing would be how much
and many people would think it would be
negligible
but no one would disagree with that
and so given this telephone game
where you can say something perfectly
innocent
and the politicians can interpret it as
saying oh so you agree that we'll have
warming
and that warming however small you know
they'll assume is the end of the world
well yeah this agreement
but right it's not agreement with what
they're ultimately claiming that it's an
existential threat
I think if you've posed it that way
you know you would for instance notice
that the un's ipcc
into governmental panel on climate
change
never in its working group one which is
the only part dealing with science
speaks of an existential threat
just right right while laurenburg has
been telling people that constantly yeah
you know he's with with his attempts to
shed some light some intelligent light
on this issue he keeps saying well look
I'm willing to accept the ipcc forecast
even though he has some problems with
the forecast he said look I'll give you
that but
the negative consequences that are often
assumed are simply not realistic you
know even there I mean you know in the
part I participated in
we said that you know the models cannot
handle
water vapor and clouds and thus there is
no basis for our
assertions about the feedbacks that was
in there
and it was interesting because
I mean the whole procedure is a little
bit nutty
I was responsible with two other people
for three pages
for this we traveled around the world
twice or three times I mean the meetings
and you had uh quote thousands of the
world's leading climate scientists
which is a field that probably had a few
dozen
at you know early in my career
and suddenly when you piled in the money
you know in the U.S I think the increase
with Clinton Gore was maybe a factor of
15.
you suddenly had thousands of quote
climate scientists
now no one in my department claimed they
were a climate scientist in 1990
because no nobody met you know I didn't
know everything about you know paleo
climate I didn't know how you assessed
ice cores I knew Dynamics I knew
radiation other people knew other things
right right but it's not a it's not a
field of specialization climate science
right I mean it is the definitive
interdisciplinary thing and nobody has
mastered all the disciplines trouble is
when you increase the funding 15 and the
condition for funding was supporting the
narrative
that you then could get lots of people
all of them calling themselves climate
scientists and most of whom have not
familiarized themselves with the physics
and the chemistry and so on
so you have this idiocy of impacts
so you know you know you've seen it you
know global warming and obesity global
warming and diabetes
I mean uh you know anyone can get a
piece of the action
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new documentary logos and
literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world
the pastor's home was the first school
and every morning it would begin with
singing the Christian faith is a singing
religion probably 80 percent of Scripps
memorization today exists only because
of what is sung
amazing here we have a Gutenberg Bible
printed on the price of Johann gubberg
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away with
at least a sense of that
well what happened to you on the funding
front when you started to
well let's say swim against the tide to
some degree although really what you
were doing was just pursuing your
research for a while
I would say in the 90s
I continued to get money from this
National Science Foundation but never
for climate I was working on
hydrodynamic instability other things
that were pure meteorological
and but by the 90s late 90s
I was known well enough for my
skepticism of climate that people were
rejecting it saying you know he'll use
some of this money for that
um NASA
also was pretty open in the 90s and so
for instance my work on feedbacks my
colleagues were from NASA
and it was okay but by the end
there was a NASA administrator who was
skeptical of climate and they got rid of
him
and they got sticked up the department
of energy was actually trying to keep
balanced funding
and then the government just clamped
down on them
and uh so so that that also means that
so that's very interesting too because
it means that
not only does the narrative spin itself
up to chase the funding but any elements
that would run contrary oh yeah
alternative just vanish oh yeah I mean
at MIT for instance uh we had a
celebration of the work of two
distinguished faculty members who had
died some years ago this Jewel Charney
and Ed Lawrence
chaos theory and so on
and you know because of my closeness to
Jewel they asked me to speak on that and
and the administration from MIT decided
no
given his position on climate and that
we have a climate initiative we can't do
that the department was quite okay they
found someone else to do that talk and I
gave another talk and so be it but the
administration was upset with that
you know it again
I mean now what's really important it's
really appalling to hear of that sort of
thing happening at MIT I mean I'm always
hoping that the engineers and the stem
types will have enough what would you
say clout and political conviction to
push back against this hyper
administrative uh invasion of the of the
technical technical schools and The
Universities
at MIT you have to think things are very
very sad that's very very sad your State
of Affairs Hope Springs Eternal but you
know we just went through
the issue of Dorian Abbott I don't know
if you heard about it yeah
oh yes yes
he was going to give a talk
on exoplanets
pretty I mean you know he's keeping away
from this issue in a way
exoplanets is
easy
but on the other hand he had written a
piece with someone from Stanford
uh for Newsweek
in which he said you know they really
didn't think diversity equity and
inclusion was that great they preferred
maintaining meritocracy
while having school choice for children
including poor children black children
so that they could be qualified for
equity
instead of it being good kind of
trap
and so mit's Administration
decided that this was not consistent
with mit's values
yeah yeah and you know a statement and
you know then it got the point who
speaks for our values
and yeah well that is the question all
right and you know this is very much the
case with almost every University every
professional society and you probably
know this
you know the people in these The Faculty
the people in professional societies are
busy they they like their work they're
doing things they like
and so you often choose one person to be
executive director or so on
and they're happy not to have to do it
or to be president of the University or
a dean uh not everyone wants to do it
they'd rather do their science yeah
research and research yeah well that's a
big problem because it leaves the
administrative Avenue opening and they
can speak for you
and speak of our values without ever
polling you that's true in the
professional societies it's true of the
National Academy in the U.S
uh there are a handful of people who can
speak for the organization and the
organization is full of people who would
rather do their work and happy to leave
them that power
yeah yeah
so have you what's been your experience
with cancellation you said it got harder
and harder for you to get grants so
that's that's that that run a lab at MIT
it also makes it almost impossible to
publish as I say editors get fired if
you get published the more common thing
is
among the peer reviewers they insist
that they be Gatekeepers
so you'll send in a paper and a lot of
people have had exactly this experience
um at first it was pretty crude so one
of the papers I published in the early
90s I had submitted to science
pointing out questions about climate
and they sent it back without review
saying there's no interest in this
oh yeah right oh yes but then no
interest right
and then they got a little bit more I
don't know if I'd call it sophisticated
uh you would send it to a journal
and uh they would reject it immediately
of some good and it came that wasn't
very effective because you send it to
another Journal
so what happened is
you typically and again this is a common
experience you send it to a journal
they take about six seven months to
review and they send back a review that
says accept it with major revision
and so you spend six months making major
revisions if you pay attention to them
send it back they take another six seven
months and reject it that got them first
time yet for a year or you know so that
you're not sending it to other journals
uh well it's also a very good way of
wasting the time oh yeah who might be
actually trying to conduct research
right
so you know all these things happen
and uh even with my students you know I
I couldn't tell them
you know
to oppose global warming
it would ruin their careers they
couldn't even get a perfect or well well
with was being associated with you
eventually was that enough to make it
difficult for your students to get a job
no I don't think so
oh well that's good that's good uh you
know I would have expected that to have
happened
no it I hadn't seen it happen
but you know I think
most of my students I think all of them
pretty much have steered clear of
climate
there are other things you can work on
just like with Dorian I mean you know uh
he doesn't want to get in trouble with
climbing pick an area which
isn't climate
the only difficulty with it is
uh funding and balance can give
preference to climate on the other hand
they've induced so many people to
support climate alarm
that they probably don't have enough
money to support all of the people who
want to go
feed at the trough
well the other problem of course is is
that
the very people who are hell-bent on
pursuing their actual research
that's where all the real scientists are
and so now if we're in a situation where
the real scientists and those would be
the ones who want to do their research
are
refusing to have anything to do with
so-called climate science then what
happens is that we're deprived of the
very expert voices that we would need to
bring some sense and stability to the
overarching narrative upon which so many
of our economic decisions are made now
so that just doesn't seem like a very
good State of Affairs it's not a good
State of Affairs but it's desired by the
people who want this state of affairs
right right
well so let me
let me recapitulate because we're
running out of time on on this section
so we talked about
we talked about your career
um and where you worked MIT and at
Harvard primarily on the academic front
we talked about the fundamental
um
climate narrative which is that well
climate's a major concern uh it's
changing primarily because the
greenhouse effect that's a consequence
of carbon dioxide most of that's warming
there are a variety of potential runaway
positive feedback loops involved
um you're not convinced of any of those
propositions that climate should be our
major concern that the greenhouse effect
as popularly conceptualized is an
existential catastrophe that carbon
dioxide is a contributor again of
existential proportions or that the
positive feedback loops that are often
put before us are likely to manifest
themselves in fact you think that the
climate system has enough degrees of
freedom to be relatively immune to
large-scale perturbations yes is that a
decent summary yeah I mean I'd modify it
a little bit uh you know I think
feedbacks and tipping points are
slightly different
and you're conflating them I don't think
this system has tipping points
uh it has feedback okay well that's the
critical issues but they're not running
away feedback loops in it yes okay so
it's the tip okay I'll make sure that I
use that technology from here on in and
then we talked about the well we tried
to investigate some of the reasons why
this more apocalyptic
narrative has gained a foothold we
talked about the malthusians we talked
about the the um the political tilt of
the funding regime we talked a little
bit more implicitly about the fact that
more apocalyptic and doom saying
prognostications tend to attract a lot
more attention and so that's a big
problem constant repetition
and the fact that children
I mean you know Al Gore no it was John
Kerry who made this statement I mean it
was just astounding I think it was in a
talk in Indonesia he said something to
the effect that we all know how
difficult physics and chemistry can be
but climate is easy enough for any child
to understand
right right which showed you the level
of his understanding well yeah but also
the impact is we're starting to teach
kindergarten children climate
yeah but you don't teach them terrifying
them yeah right your world is coming to
an end in 10 years unless your parents
stop eating meat or you know God knows
what right or driving their vehicle or
hitting their house or Grandma warm or
recharging their electric car well that
all right so so so let me let me offer a
set of propositions to the listeners and
and stop me or clarify what I'm saying
if I get it wrong so there are lots of
drivers of climate variation the big
drivers have to do with oscillations in
planetary orbit or other comparative
effect of or or other factors yeah there
are so many factors that would impact it
uh there are ocean currents uh you know
for instance
again it's a technical term but the
surface of the Earth
is not isolated you know it's not in
equilibrium with space
it has the oceans underneath it
ocean circulations have time scales up
to a thousand years and they're
constantly bringing fluid up and taking
fluid away from the surface and that
fluid is carrying Heat
and so the system is never quite an
equilibrium it varies on its own
until we understand these systems
perfectly well
we don't necessarily have a good theory
for the fact that you know there was a
medieval warm period there was
evidence of a warm period you know 2 000
years ago all sorts of things
there were things
oddly enough I mean let's say at the
beginning of the 19th century
in New England every town had a learned
Society
and they had their proceedings and you
would look at these old documents of
Ordinary People well ordinary educated
people at that time
discussing whether
Rome when they had Vineyards and so on
and so on was warmer than it is at their
time they're still in little ice age
and they were wondering if it was just
reportage or there was something really
different had climate changed they were
doing sophisticated thinking about it
which is virtually disappeared from our
world
we also talked about the 97 percent of
scientists fallacy and you pointed out
that 97 of scientists likely agree that
carbon dioxide plays a role in
greenhouse warming phenomenon yeah but
that doesn't mean that 97 percent of
scientists believe that there are
tipping points built into the climate
and that we're going to slide off the
edge of an abyss within the next hundred
years oh no those are very different
claims no and and it's
you know as I say I mean
I
was speaking at a group I think uh
doctors for disaster preparedness and
they'd give me some recognition and I
decided that I would point out who
opposed this narrative
during the early 90s or the 90s
and it was leading figures in the field
uh and Bill Nye the science man on TV or
something
was saying that you know
uh
these are just old people who they'll
die soon and we'll we won't have these
objections
and there was some truth to that I mean
you had directors of major Labs
directors of the MOX plunk
people who are heading the European
medium range weather forecasting which
is a premier group
all of them objecting to it
uh presidents of the National Academy
and so on
but
starting in the 90s with the Takeover of
major funding institutions and so on
um you weren't going to get many younger
people
right right okay so if we close this off
and maybe we could do this if you if you
maybe you could take 30 seconds or get a
lot of relatively young people watching
this YouTube channel and you know
they're worried because they've been fed
a non-ending diet of apocalyptic
catastrophe and oppressive patriarchy
since they were like three and so if you
wanted to address them directly and say
what you wanted to say about what we can
expect over the next 50 years let's say
because that's kind of not a bad
lifespan uh Viewpoint or 75 years what
what what do you think what should we be
contemplating on the climate front
much the same as we've seen
you'll see variations
they've always occurred
there will be places like the gulf coast
of the US
which had been a citrus country in the
40s
and now it's too cold
for citrus other things will change
things always change a bit
there may be you know several inches of
sea level rise
uh but not a lot more there's no
evidence it'll be much more
um
you'll still have a situation where if
you live in New England
Mark Twain's remark you know
wait a minute and the weather will
change will still be true
um
and you know that's life
that's why you have overcoats and gloves
and uh
swimsuits
and there would be nothing special it's
not cataclysmic
uh you're not going to be uh inundated
with hungry uh polar bears fleeing the
Arctic
you're not going to have uh
cities underwater
um and you know get on with your life
but the question is if your teacher
insists on your saying the world is
coming to an end or you won't get
promoted I'm not sure what I should tell
them
well I've told I've told my students my
whole life said never you don't don't
falsify your words because the thing is
you know I'll tell you an experiment a
psychological experiment that's quite
interesting it might even be valid so
imagine you bring people in
to the lab young people and you give
them a political attitudes questionnaire
regarding their views on a particular
topic maybe abortion maybe climate
whatever some topic that's you know
relatively contentious
then you have them sit down and write a
500 word essay arguing against their
position
now they know they're doing this in a
lab then you bring them in a week later
and you give them the same political
attitudes questionnaire
you find that their attitudes have
shifted substantially and significantly
towards the direction of their writing
and so the problem is
you can't falsify the word your words
without falsifying your thinkings yeah
because your your words construct your
perceptions and so if you kowtow to the
teacher's ideology we found this too
when we were looking at what predicted
politically correct beliefs
so the trait agreeableness did being
female did
um having a lower verbal IQ did but
another major predictor was whether or
not you'd taken any courses at all that
were explicitly politically corrected
their orientation
so you have to be very careful about
kowtowing to the ideology because you
can't get away with it you'll you'll
falsify your own psyche if you falsify
your words
you know I think
I agree with what you're saying
but 1984
[Music]
you know was a fairly good example of
how Society can break that down
yeah and so you've maintained your
ground you've maintained your ground how
come
age
in other words you know it's the
business that for scientists of an older
generation up to mine
pretty much maybe a little further
uh we could develop our reputations our
work product
over a Freer time
[Music]
yeah the other thing is theoreticians
don't need as much money as
experimenters
and so I needed money just to support
students
I didn't need equipment I didn't need
very much of anything else right right
um but it was mainly that people were
advanced in their career if you were a
director of a lab and so on if you were
near retirement
you could speak freely
the more sad were the weatherman
the people the media forecasters and so
on
who had a love of meteorology in many
cases were very knowledgeable
and uh
objected to this by and large I would go
on a train ride or something and
meteorologists from the media would see
me in there and say thank you
for that but the media have been firing
people
who don't
attribute every weather event to climate
right and the meteorologists know this
is nonsense but they just you know are
being pressured immensely
and we were lucky our jobs were not at
issue we had tenure and so on
yeah uh but younger people
don't have that luxury
yeah while I'm being canceled is no fun
I mean I've known like 200 people who've
been counseled and it's about equivalent
to a major illness it's no joke so all
right sir well look for everybody who's
been watching and listening on YouTube
thank you very much for your time and
attention and Dr lindsen thank you very
much for your calm and dispassionate
and kind I would say analysis of the
current situation and for agreeing to
speak to me today and to to uh for be
providing all the people who are
watching and listening with the fruits
of your Decades of Labor and for I'm
going to talk to Dr lindsen for another
half an hour on the daily wire plus
platform by the way probably on a more
biographical front I'm interested in how
his career developed
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com